[Music]
the smart irrigation
smartwatch discussion paper is developed
by the land and water division of
fao as a contribution to the topical
debate on the rapidly evolving situation
of covet 19
and its impact on nutrition
and food security beyond the
well-defined health risks
undoubtedly exploiting irrigation
potential
has a major role in enhancing food
security
however expanding irrigation entails
considerable
growth in water use meanwhile provision
of safe water for sanitation is the
precondition to slow down the spread of
the pandemic
the twin track smart irrigation
smartwatch
approach clearly embodies
that water resources should be employed
for multiple uses
in order to respond to both food
security and health needs
the fight against the pandemic is a
marathon
not a sprint as far as emergency
interventions
can be highly beneficial in reducing
the most negative impacts of hunger and
pandemics
countries are required to define their
strategies
to protect the most vulnerable and
ensure
the resources are available for the most
basic
human needs food security and human
health
this evolving assessment starts with the
identification
of geographical hotspots of copied-19
impacts
in the context of agriculture food
production
and hygiene the mapping is carried out
along
largely agreed risky indicators
food insecurity and health
the probability of food security impacts
is assessed through irrigated
agriculture
and the probability of has impact
through the provision
of safe water countries with the most
overlapping levels of vulnerability
are identified as potential hotspots
on the other side the spreading trend of
the pandemic
is analyzed considering also the
reliability
of reported cases the intersection
between countries with high
vulnerability
related to agricultural production and
countries with high vulnerability
related to the pandemic spread are
finally defined
as geographical hotspots
after the vulnerability mapping and
analysis investment categorization
matrix is completed
the investment packages for
interventions can be proposed for the
affected countries
here we can divide the investment
packages into two levels of
interventions
the on-farm level and the system level
there are hundreds of system-level water
conservation technologies
however a set of selected technologies
that meet the multiple use criteria are
presented in this paper to address the
challenges under consideration that is
the food security and public hygiene
you